[Music]
all week long we've been keeping you in
front of every twist and turn in the
bachelor in paradise sex scandal and
there are new developments to tell you
about tonight
jasmine good was teen Corrine when the
two appeared together on The Bachelor
she was also in paradise and her
allegation Corrine is not a victim
Jasmine tells us quote what I saw
between them looked like a normal couple
having fun hooking up like any other
season a paradise after the incident
everything seemed fine there was no
mention about being hurt
however when producers tried to cut her
off from drinking she got upset and said
watch watch what I'm gonna do friends
lawyer responded quickly saying quote if
nothing improper occurred on the set of
bachelor in paradise
why was the production shut down within
two days well there's still no word on
whether or not bachelor in paradise will
continue as a series when the previous
season aired last summer the show was
watched for nearly five million people
each week
you